yeah all right good all right excellent
we're gonna get started then I know a
few people are still filtering but it's
a good time to start
so hello nice to see you all I really
love coming to NDC conferences they are
among my favorite of all the software
conferences which is why I've
particularly wanted to come out to this
one and I hope you have a gonna have a
really good time especially if it's your
first NDC and now before we get started
I'd really just like to get a bit of a
sense of who's in the room so can you
give me a signal but of your hand if you
do any sort of client-side web
development today with some framework
like angular react view knockout Elm
yeah anything like that yeah all right
so I'd say that's about half of the room
maybe a touch over hand and how many of
you are dotnet developers that's like
two-thirds ok cool so we've got some
good overlap there and finally how many
of you I've ever heard of this blazer
thing and have some sort of vague sense
of what that is all right that's about
the third of you might be maybe close to
a half as well okay good all right so I
think you are in the right room and this
should be fun so my name is Steve and I
work at Microsoft and I'm on the asp net
team and I've had quite a lot of
different roles on the ASP Knut team
over the years but mostly I focused on
client-side scenarios things where
people are trying to write JavaScript in
a browser historically and I've done a
bunch of stuff on that but more recently
I've had this opportunity to work on a
very exciting new experimental project
to bring dotnet into the browser and
that's what this is all about today so
we're going to get into that into in a
lot of detail obviously that's what the
talk is about but before we get to it I
just want to raise this question of why
on earth is this relevant why should
anybody be trying to push this sort of
thing why should you care and and is
this really relevant to our industry so
let's take a step back and think about
software more generally what kind of
software exists what sort of platforms
can people target what kind of languages
can people use well of course software
can run on personal computers desktops
or laptops that's a very traditional way
of thinking about software
and as well as that since the late 90s
at least there's been a strong market
for native mobile apps as well which is
you know more or less the same thing but
just on a smaller screen and that's not
all besides that a lot of us write code
that's designed to run on servers and of
course those servers these days there's
a good chance they're going to be in the
cloud but maybe it's just some machine
that's under someone's desk somewhere
but basically writing code that runs on
a server also takes up a lot of our time
there are other types of software too
for example games of course there are
many different game consoles and
different pieces of gaming hardware as
well as writing games for mobiles and
other types of devices and finally
there's software that runs on embedded
devices so that might be embedded into
some kind of scientific equipment like
on this icon or maybe it's software that
powers a car or a space shuttle or a
children's toy or anything else like
that embedded software okay so lots of
different types of software and one
thing that all the things have got in
common is that when you're building this
software you've got a wide range of
choices of languages and technology
platforms that you can choose to use you
can use very high-level languages like
manage languages such as Java or.net or
you could use very low-level languages
like you could write plain machine code
if you wanted or something in C and as
well as that there are lots of languages
that target specific specializations
such as scientific programming or
functional program if you if you want to
think of that as a specialization with
languages like Haskell so the software
industry is pretty maturing there's a
wide range of choices for you for your
team to decide what's best for the kind
of problems you're solving and what
skill set your background is but there's
another type of software as well that
greatly concerns me and that is software
that's designed to run in a browser and
you could make the argument that browser
is the biggest runtime there is in the
world there are more people who can run
software in a browser than anything else
but one thing that's not so cool about
browser development is that until very
recently you're essentially limited to
one language it's been the domain
exclusively of JavaScript now I know
that there are other languages that
compile to JavaScript and the Riva some
edge case type things like elm but
more or less everyone is doing stuff
that resembles JavaScript even if it
compiles to JavaScript it's the same
runtime the same basic set of
constraints the same basic kind of feel
and that is a shame for us as an
industry because it means that we're not
able to take advantage of all the
advances that are taking place in the
rest of software wouldn't it be nicer if
web development could grow up a little
bit and join the rest of the software
industry with a much broader spectrum of
choices for developers and that wasn't
really possible until recently because
of this marvelous thing that's swooping
in to save us all which is web
assembling I'm sure you've heard of it
web assembly is a bytecode format that
is now supported in all up-to-date
browsers including mobiles and the idea
with web assembly is you can compile
from whenever language you want to web
assembly and then you can run that code
directly in the browser and you don't
have to just use one specific type of
thing so that is a very promising
development for web developers and that
of course gets us thinking what sort of
things would we like to run our web
assembly and I'm part of the.net team so
of course for me one of my main
interests is well could we run no on web
assembly and would anyone want to do
that what sort of benefits would there
be well I think we can probably agree
that there is a bunch of benefits that
would be of interest to web developers
if this was a realistic option for
example unlike the world of JavaScript
dotnet is relatively stable and mature
it's been around for what 18 years now
and it's largely maintained about
compatibility throughout that process
it's very very constant and reliable
year after year for getting your work
done as well as that it's maintained a
reputation of being very fast and secure
the current don't net core runtimes is
going to be able to run your code just
about as fast as any code that you're
gonna write in a much lower level
language while giving you a much higher
level of productivity as a developer but
you know that if you rode on a developer
and the rest of you would probably agree
that it can be said for other managed
languages as well
okay there's been tons of innovation in
the languages in dotnet space of course
in C sharp and F sharp they're always
adding new features pretty much on a
monthly basis so that's always remaining
up to date and then finally
the thing that Microsoft's developed
division has always had a reputation for
its building first-rate development
tooling so industry-leading productivity
in your IDs there so quite a bundle of
benefits that if it were realistically
possible to run in a browser would
hopefully be interesting and until a few
years ago it was possible because we had
Silverlight and you could run dotnet in
the browser on a plugin but that doesn't
really work in the modern world plugins
so webassembly gives us a new
opportunity to reinvent the idea of
dotnet in a browser but purely based on
open standards and running on any device
and that's what brings us to blazer
blazer is our experimental project from
the dotnet from the asp net team
specifically that's looking into what
would it be like to build daunt
applications in the black browser in a
very modern way so it's a user interface
stack that runs on net which itself runs
on web assembly in any browser okay now
if you're wondering where the name for
blazer comes from well it's a
composition of two words the A's apart
of it comes from Razer which is the
c-sharp and HTML syntax that we'll be
seeing a lot of in this talk and the
blue part of it obviously comes from
blockchain because you know what chains
really cool and everything should be
block sharing these days right and we
haven't admittedly figured out how
blockchain is involved in this yet but
when we do we'll add that into a future
version not really not really of course
that becomes from browser because we're
ruining Razer inside a browser and the L
it just sounds better there we go that's
a perfectly good business justification
all right so that's a blazer and that's
why I want to show you in some detail in
this talk the way we're gonna structure
this talk is in two parts so in the
first part I want to show you what it's
like to create a new blazer application
I'll show you what the project templates
are like and I'll use that as an
opportunity to explain to you how it's
working behind the scenes and after
we've got some of that basic level
information about how this is working I
want to move on to building a bigger
application so don't want to just get
stuck at the hello world level and when
I show you some more interesting
architectural questions
and some of the more advanced things
that you can do with laser so we'll move
on to them but let's get started with
creating a new project and there are a
couple of different project types
available in Glaser right now the
simplest one is to create a pure
client-side application that's just
running Donna in the browser and doesn't
have any opinions about what you're
doing on the server so I'm going to
create a project and I'm gonna do it
using visual studio on Windows now
that's what we've got the best tooling
for at the moment longer term we hope to
expand that to to be more cross-platform
and to be support other kinds of
development environments but where we're
starting right now in this project is
envious of Windows so what I've done
already is I've installed the blazer
extension for visual studio and at the
end of this talk I'll give you the link
so you can go and download that as well
yourself and once I've done that I can
create a new project so I'll go file new
project and from the list of project
types I'll choose an ASP neck or web
application and we'll give it a name
let's call it NDC blaze or and also go
on that and then it'll say alright what
kind of ASP nut core application do you
want to produce and we've got all the
usual choices but because I've installed
this extension we've also got these two
Blazer options as well so I'm going to
choose a plain blazer standalone
client-side application first and it's
going to create that project for me and
it's going to fetch and install all of
the dependencies necessary so I should
be able to compile this and get it
running okay now first I want to show it
running in a browser so you can see what
the application starting point UI looks
like and then we'll jump into the code
and see how it's actually implemented
and how you can build more stuff with it
so I'm gonna pop that up in a browser
and when my server starts responding to
me in a few seconds we should see the
initial UI coming up there okay so as
you can see the project template creates
something that's a bit like a dashboard
type application because that's a very
common scenario for this sort of
technology and what's in there well
we've got
side back forward navigation might you'd
expect and we've got a couple of
examples of components so we've got this
counter component here that just counts
the number of times that you've clicked
on a button and we've also got the
simple fetch data example which makes an
HTTP request to some location on a
server fetches some JSON data and
renders it as an HTML table okay pretty
simple stuff so this is the sort of
application that traditionally people
would build with a JavaScript library
like view or react or angular or that
sort of thing so let's have a look in
our project and we'll try and spot the
JavaScript shall we let's see what files
we've got in here well we've got some
CSS and some HTML we've got the CS HTML
files that's RAZR files which I'll show
you in a second and we've got jason
config and we've got a c-sharp file so
there's no JavaScript at all in this
application it's purely a dotnet plus
HTML and CSS application and as for what
these components are and what they do
and how they work well let's take a look
at one let's start with the counter
component so if you recall it just
counts the number of times that you
click on a button the implementation for
that looks like this okay so this is
razor I expect a lot have you've seen it
but if you haven't raised there is a
syntax for combining HTML and C sharp in
a pretty natural kind of way and what
we're doing here is at the top we've got
this directive called page and this
tells the router that this component
acts as the handler for a particular URL
so any Blaser component can act as a
handler for URL if you want it to but
they don't all have to it's up to you
this one listens for the counter URL and
it's going to display a little bit of
HTML it's also got some c-sharp so we've
got this variable current count that's
going to show how many times you've
clicked
we'll use razor syntax to display that
current count value and we've got a
button that says when you click it we're
going to call this c-sharp method
increment count and that will increment
it and everything will update okay that
makes sense reasonable clear yeah no no
obvious objections all right so let's
have a look at another one let's have a
look at this fetch data on this is an
example of making an HTTP request and
again it's got the page directive up at
the top there this has also got an
injector
because blazer applications support
dependency injection so we can inject
services into components here we're
injecting an HTTP client that lets us
make requests that's the standard dotnet
HTTP client that a lot of you will be
familiar with and then down at the
bottom we've got some c-sharp code we're
declaring a class to specify what kind
of data we're expecting to get back from
the server and then we can use normal C
sharp programming like a sink and a
weight and HTTP GET requests to fetch
some data turn it into an array of
weather forecasts and then up here we
can use some razor code to render an
HTML table very straightforward kind of
things now because this is a standalone
client only application there's no
server to get data from so we're just
fetching the static JSON file from disk
but in other cases you would call a
actual server-side end point but the
client-side code doesn't know or care
about that all right so that's some
basics now let me show you a little bit
more stuff that you can do with
components so I'm going to be trying to
impress upon you the fact that
components are a very flexible concept
that you can do almost anything that you
want to with components for example one
of the most basic and useful things you
can do is use one component inside
another here's the index page this is
like the home page here so as you can
see it's displaying this how is Blaser
working for you thing down there and
that is coming from another component
which is called survey prompt and we can
trivially just use any component inside
another so if for whatever crazy reason
I decide that I want to have a counter
on my home page I can simply type out
counter I get intellisense
and then my counter is going to be added
to the application right there
so if I come back and I reload in the
browser now we should see we've got a
counter right there on the home page as
well and of course it's a functional
counter because all components just
encapsulate their own behaviors and
that's going to work fine but we can do
more stuff with it than that
for example we can pass parameters into
them let's say instead of incrementing
by one every time I want it to go up by
a variable amount so I'm going to go to
my counter and I'm going to add a
parameter parameter of type int and I'll
call it increment
amount and we'll give that some getters
and setters and an in default value of
one and I'll say when we call this
method we're going to increase by the
increment amount okay and so now here
where I've got this counter I want to
use this increment amount parameter so I
can just use the intellisense pick the
parameter that I want to pass let's say
I want it to increment by eights now and
then hopefully it will do what I have
told it so let's come back and reload
and now when I click this you'll see
it's going up in eighths
rather than once where is this other
counter it still goes up in once because
I haven't passed any parameter to that
okay so that gives you a bit of sense of
some things that you can do with
components but I ever really explained
very much about how this works behind
the scenes yeah I'm sure some of you are
thinking well hang on this is dotnet and
it's running on web assembly but how
does that work like how does the browser
know to run dotnet what what are you
even sending to the browser anyway is
this running on the server in some way
well let me show you okay probably the
easiest way to understand it is by
looking at the browser's network tab so
we can see exactly what stuff we're
sending to the browser so I'm gonna do a
hard reload there and let's start by
talking about how big this thing is
so we're embedding an entire dotnet
runtime into a page here so what's that
going to be like hundreds of Meg's well
firstly we can see it's 18 HTTP requests
totaling 1.8 one megabytes so 1.8 one
makes it's pretty small for a dotnet
runtime but it's also and still a little
bit big for a web application so I'm
sure some of you would like it to be
smaller than that we want it to be
smaller than that as well sometimes we
talk to customers in the say hey I don't
care I'm writing internal apps I don't
mind if it's 10 Meg's it's no problem
for me but at least those of us on the
team are very determined that we're
going to make this number quite a lot
smaller we've got lots of optimizations
lined up that we intend to get this
number out of the box to be a much lower
value than 1.8
Meg's but anyway we're only just getting
started with the optimizations right now
so this is what we've got and what does
1.8 Meg's buy you these days well what
do you get for your 1.8 Meg's you get
some HTML that we're initially sending
down to the browser we're getting some
CSS as well
we got some JavaScript so blazer doc Jas
where's that coming from we don't have
any JavaScript in our solution so
where's this Jas coming from and what's
this thing mono wasum what's mono
involved in this for this is webassembly
of course
so why some is the file extension work
for web assembly binaries and mono is
the dotnet runtime that we are using
here as I'm sure many of you will be
aware there are lots of different at
runtime available there's not that
framework that's done at core there's
core Artie there's mono and there's
probably loads of other ones as well the
idea with all of this is that there's a
standard it's called dotnet standard and
when you write your code and compile it
against dotnet standard then your code
can run on any dotnet standard compliant
run type a mono is for dotnet runtime it
in fact is Microsoft's official
preferred dotnet runtime for client
scenarios so for things like native
mobile apps and for things like games on
unity so mono is an incredibly widely
used incredibly mature and stable dotnet
runtime it's been around for a long time
and the current versions of it are
compliant with dotnet standard 2 or 2 1
or whatever they've got too right now so
that's what we use in here we've got a
build of mono which is compiled to web
assembly and so it can run inside the
browser and because we've got that we
can send regular dotnet assemblies down
into the browser so when you compile
your a blazer application we're not
compiling your c-sharp into JavaScript
or web assembly or anything like that
we're just compiling normal dotnet
assemblies and that's why the build
times can be so fast it just uses all
the existing tool chain and then we send
these normal dotnet assemblies down into
the browser and we load them into mono
Dasom and it just runs them and we are
very happy about that ok so that's some
of what's going on but let's understand
a little bit more where were these J's
files coming from and how does the
browser even know to load all this stuff
well let's have a look in here let's
have a look at this index dot HTML file
this is the initial HTML that gets sent
down to the browser when the user loads
your page and the idea here is that this
is your HTML and you can do
whatever you want with that so you can
come to this file and you can add your
own CSS your own references or the
JavaScript or meta tags or whatever you
want entirely up to you
the only special but is this script type
equals blazer boot and that is the magic
thing that knows how to load and
kickstart the blazer application so what
happens is when you compile your
application we replace that script tag
with something that the browser can
understand so by the time this gets to
the browser it looks slightly different
it looks like this so it's the same
content that you just saw before but the
script type equals blazer boot has been
replaced by this other script tag which
loads a file that's embedded into the
framework called blazer J s and that in
turn knows how to load and start up the
mono web assembly runtime it also gets a
bit of configure bout like what your
application entry point is and what
you're referencing things like that so
that is how the browser is able to load
and start up the Dom app runtime there
so I hope that makes sense to you and
that's how we can create a pure
client-side application when you publish
this application what you get out of it
is a set of static files and you can
deploy those static files to any web
server that can serve static files which
is all of them so you don't need to have
dotnet on the server you can deploy to
anything that you feel like it could be
github pages if you want to we've got an
example of that it could be as a blob
storage anything at all you don't need
our net on the server if you don't want
to but we know that a lot of people do
want to have Donna and the server and
there are some significant advantages to
using the same platform for both server
and client so we've got another project
template as well an example of setting
up a blazer application that is
connected to an asp net core back end
let me show you that I'm gonna close
this solution and then I'm gonna go a
file new project and this time I'm going
to choose blazer asp net core hosted
okay and we'll see what comes out of
there will be a little bit different
from what we had before
although when it's running it will
hopefully look exactly the same should
have the same functionality as far as an
end user
so I'm just bringing that up in a
browser to show you that right now and
we can see that it looks exactly the
same bus before it's got the same
functionality the only thing that's
really different is this time instead of
fetching a plain JSON file from disk
it's making a request to a real API
endpoint on the ESPN app server so let's
have a quick look at some of the codes
that we've got up here you can see that
unlike where we just had one project
before we've now got three different
projects client-server and shared now
you can probably guess what each of
those three things are but in case
you're being a little bit dim this
morning I'm going to just quickly run
through each of those client obviously
is the Blazer client application it's
the same thing that we saw before it's
got the same set of components in it it
works basically the same apart from when
it's talking to the server then we've
got the server project which is a normal
dotnet core SP net core web application
the only thing that's a little bit
special about it is that this thing
knows how to host the blazer user
interface so this is the application
that we're actually starting up and
running there and it returns the Blazer
UI and the way it knows how to do that
is that it detect it takes a dependency
on the Blazer client application we've
got a project reference to it there and
then when we configure the application
request processing pipeline down here in
this configure method we're configuring
usual SP nightcore stuff but then we've
got this exciting little thing down here
this new bit of middleware use blazer
takes a reference it says well which
blazer application do you want me to
host and then it's going to return the
user interface for that and this is set
up to work correctly both when you're
building and running locally it also
works correctly with publishing so when
you publish this server project it's
going to automatically include
everything it needs from the client
application as well so when you deploy
it your client app will just show up
okay and then the third and final
project perhaps the most interesting Ron
conceptually at least is this shared
project now this is just a standard
dotnet standard class library and you
can just put all normal class library
things in there and as you can probably
guess the whole point of this is that we
can share code now trivially between
server and client and that's really
useful particularly for things like
domain classes so here I've got this
weather forecast class that defines the
information that the server and client
will be exchanging and then we can use
this in both the server and client
projects so here's the server-side code
here that's going to return a set of
weather forecasts just random data but
you get the idea and then on the client
we don't have to define another copy of
that type definition inside fetch data
here you'll see we don't have our own
fetch data class we just use the one
from the shared project so getting some
data from the server is trivial it's
just give me a bunch of weather
forecasts please and the server does and
that makes the development experience
really really convenient because you're
not dealing with this awkward mismatch
between server and client technologies
you're not having to worry about like
how stuff is represented differently in
different ways and about trying to keep
stuff in sync between your server-side
code and your client-side code it's
always in sync it's literally just the
same class and you can just exchange
instances as long as they're Jason
serializable so that makes things very
straight forwards for you as a developer
ok so that's some basic hello world type
stuff but you're you're not a beginner
audience right you're a fairly advanced
bunch of people and you're hopefully
going to be interested in taking this a
little bit further I want to show you
now a bigger more sophisticated
application that gives me an opportunity
to talk about some architectural stuff
with you and about some of the more
advanced features inside blazer so I'm
going to show you a sample application
that we've been working on
it's called flight finder and the idea
with flight finder it's a bit like a
sort of travel booking tool so you can
go and search for flights and then when
you see some flights that you like you
can add them to a shortlist and compare
them and decide which fly is the best
one for you I think you want to book ok
so I'm going to walk you through a
series of different features and
functionality that we're going to add to
this application starting with how it is
structured and how it managers state
within the application ok so let's open
the source code for this right now
where is it it's right here okay and
like usual I want to start by running it
in a browser so that you can see what
sort of thing this is so we popping that
open here can close these other tabs
probably and you will see here's the
initial UI and it lets us search for
flight so for example let's say that I
want to go from Minneapolis st. Paul's
there and I would like to go to I don't
know Miami International why not and I
would like to depart when would I like
to depart maybe tomorrow and then I'll
come back on I don't know oh there's a
bit of a book here I've just noticed at
this exact moment that should probably
say return not arrived because it we had
to be able to specify when you arrive
like oh I want to be in the eighth of
nine days please that'll be fun
anyway let's not worry about that let's
imagine that this is a business trip
okay so our employers are paying for it
so I think quite legitimately we can go
with first riah corporate travel policy
probably allows that I would hope and
then we'll click on search and we'll get
back some data from the server now if I
click this more than once it would sound
completely different day two each time
and if you know the airline industry
you'll know it's kind of matter the idea
that Qantas would be flying that route
and that the price differences would be
like this so as you can probably guess
this is not real data this talk is not
about the complicated world of airline
pricing algorithms or airline routing or
anything like that so I'm just returning
random data but you get the idea this is
about building the actual client-side UI
so we can do searches and then we can
eventually add some flights to our short
list but how is it implemented well
let's have a look okay as you see it's
the same project structure that I just
showed you before in the Blazer hosted
template so we've got a client project a
server and a shared and like you'd
expect the client project has got a
bunch of Blaser components that
represent different parts of the UI
things like the search area and search
results and other things like that
we'll get to more of that in a minute
then we've also got a server project
which is a normal asp net core server
and it's got a couple of different
controllers that can return data when
you
issue searches and then finally we've
got our shared project and inside shared
we can add all the stuff that's common
to both server and clone so in this case
my domain types are things like airport
airports have got a code in the name
we've got flight segment which has got
like airline departure Day arrival date
that sort of thing and we've got an
itinerary which combines an outbound
segment and a return segment and has a
price
we've got search criteria and that
models the stuff that the user would
type into the search controls such as
which Airport they're going from and -
and oh look I got the type name correct
there so that's the return date and
we've got a ticket class which itself is
an enum and then we've got some
extension methods on that to render that
out to some nice human readable strings
okay so that's some what makes sense and
the point of having all of these types
inside our shared project is that we can
use them on our server and we can
exchange data in a very convenient way
with the client for example here's the
flight search controller on the server
it's a normal asp net core api endpoint
and it's going to receive from the
client a strongly typed search criteria
object containing all the information
that the user entered into that box and
it's going to return a set of
itineraries and like I said before the
data returns it just random but it's up
to you as an exercise to put in a real
crisis accrual system if you actually
want to do that kind of thing and then
on the client we can of course make
requests and we get back our data in a
nice strongly tight way and we can just
render it okay so I hope that makes
sense
but let's have a look at some of these
plays or components now in fact the only
one that I really want to focus on
initially is this one down here main dot
CSS HTML because that's where the
application all comes together inside
main we're defining the overall
structure of the UI and as you can see
at the top we've got this search
component there whether user types in
their search criteria below that we've
got search results and below that we've
got shortlist or rather we will do later
when
Herman today in about five minutes but
there's some other pretty weird stuff in
here as well that's probably making you
wonder what on earth is going on so what
is this what is an app state why are we
injecting it what are we injecting it
with is that morally acceptable and what
is this thing down here at the bottom
what is this on in it
what is the state that might change and
what is state has changed a lot of weird
stuff going on there so this opens up
the question of how we're going to
manage track states within the
application how do we know when things
change who's responsible for maintaining
that state over time now if you look at
the wider landscape of single page
application frameworks like react for
your angular and all the others there
are many many different ways of managing
client-side States everyone's got their
own way of doing it and it keeps
changing all the time what people think
the best way of doing it is but there's
one pattern in particular that has risen
to the top in the last couple years and
has largely become accepted as probably
the best way to do this thing and this
is the idea of a state container a state
container is a fairly simple concept
it's just the idea that instead of
having all of your states scattered
through all your different components
you would centralize that stay into one
place that deals with the business logic
around how it should update and it
should have a way of issuing
notifications to tell all the different
parts of the UI when they should update
and that's what I'm doing here now if I
was implementing this in something like
view or react I would probably use a
state container framework because there
are plenty of them out there and some of
them are pretty good but I'm not I'm
doing this in dotnet and in the.net
world there aren't really very many
mature State container frameworks I
expect there probably will be fairly
soon when people decide that they want
to start making them and building open
source projects around that and some of
them have actually started but it's
still early days for that right now so
rather than using one of them I want to
just write my own state container just
as a simple trivial c-sharp class it's
gonna be super super basic and hopefully
expresses the basic concepts so I've got
this class called app state here and my
app stay like I said is responsible for
tracking
day and knowing when it changes and the
only state I need to track right now are
what are the search results we're
currently displaying and this boolean
flag that says is the search currently
in progress or not and the other thing
we have to do is have a way of issuing
notifications when things change and
there are loads of different ways you
could do that you could use observables
you could use inotify property changed
or other patterns like that
but I wanted to keep this really basic
so I'm going to use a good old fashioned
c-sharp event that says that stuff has
changed and of course I could have
different events to say when this
different things have changed but for
now is completely sufficient just to
have one event okay so that is how we're
basically structuring this application
and managing its state but it's kind of
a bit hard to get all that into your
head at once you might feel that you
don't have a really good handle on how
all this stuff is really working so to
give you a better sense of what this is
really like I think we should now add a
new feature of our own and then you'll
get a sense of whether this is really a
nice sort of technology to work with and
whether these kind of patterns are going
to scale to the sort of applications
that you want to do okay so what feature
do we want to add well I want to
implement the short list over here right
now it's not implemented so when I click
on these add bones you'll see and click
in and nothing is happening
well actually something is happening but
you just can't see it if you want to see
it we need to open up the browsers
console here and then when I click on
add you'll see it displays this message
to do implement shortlist okay so why is
it displaying that why is it logging
that message well if we look in our
state container down here you'll see
we've got this method add to shortlist
and it's not a very complete method
right now all it does is it logs this
message okay so we want to implement
that and to implement it first we're
going to have to have a place to store
the state relating to the short list
that is we're going to have a list of
itineraries that the user is added and I
want to store that so I'm going to go up
here to the place where I'm storing all
these states in properties and I'm going
to add a couple more properties I'm
going to add this one firstly so
privately we can have a list of
itineraries and we can modify this list
over time it's not a redundant list it's
a readwrite list we can add and remove
stuff
- and then publicly we're going to
expose a read-only view of the same data
so in general you'll want your state
containers to be encapsulated so the
state container itself is the only thing
that can modify its own state and that
gives you confidence that you've got a
central place to put any business logic
associated with those state changes and
that you can ensure that notifications
are raised correctly so anyway we've got
our place to store the short list now so
very trivially inside our two short list
I can just say short list to add
itinerary and then if we want anyone to
know that we've just done that we will
call notify state changed and all that
is is a method that raises the on church
event and like I said there are lots of
different ways that you could do this
but if you're going to do it as a simple
c-sharp event this is a very basic way
of doing it okay so we are now tracking
the state of the short list but we're
not displaying anything on the UI yet so
I want to make a new UI component that's
actually going to display the short list
okay so I'm going to add a new component
using add new item and we haven't yet
implemented any item template for Blaser
components we probably should get on
with doing that we haven't done it's
good enough at the moment just to create
a raise of you and I'm gonna call this
one shortlist
okay so when that has been created we've
got a new razor file here and we can
type anything we want to so I'm going to
put a little message hello from from the
new short list very good okay and then I
want to use that so I'll go back to main
dot CSS HTML I'm gonna say we'll have a
short list right there if you please and
so when I go back to the browser and
reload now we should see did I not do
that what did I not do that let's try
that one more time if I reload then
we'll get okay
hello from the new short list so it's
using our new component that very good
but I don't just want display the
message I want to display the actual
short list contents so I'm going to pass
the data that I want my short list to
have into it I don't want to wire up my
short list directly to the state
container I could but it's generally
considered good practice not to wire up
everything individually because then you
end up with this complex
of lots of stuff updating independently
it's generally simpler for you if you
just wire up a few things
few top-level things to your state
container and then pass the data that
each the component needs into end just
like I'm passing the itineraries into
search results here I want to pass the
short list into the short list component
so just like I showed you before I can
define what parameters my short list
component takes and I'm going to say
it's going to take something called
itineraries which is going to be a
collection of itineraries and when I've
got that I can display something from
there so let's say a short list and to
get started I'm just gonna display
itineraries dot count so we know how
many things are in it and now on the
short list here I want to make use of
this itineraries property so I will here
we go okay so I'm going to add
itineraries and I'm gonna pass state
dart short list into it so my short list
should get the data and it should be
updated when that changes okay so if
I've done this correctly then when I
come back and reload it's now going to
say a short list zero and then when I
start clicking on these buttons you'll
see that that number is going to
increase because it's adding stuff into
that collection and it's updating good
right this is a good start but we don't
want to just display a number we want to
display the actual contents of the short
list so I'll go back over here and I'm
going to drop in a little bit of markup
that have prepared so simply using razor
syntax I can say for each of the
itineraries I'm gonna display a little
box that displays initially I'm just
going to display the airline that you
are traveling with just so that we can
check that this is working correctly so
now when I click these buttons let's get
some more stuff okay we'll get KLM and
then we'll get Emirates and then we'll
get ba and we can just keep on going
like that okay so it's working but we
don't just want to display the airline
name we want to display all the
information about the itinerary so to do
that we just need to add more Ray's a
markup and that's kind of boring so I'm
not going to go through it step-by-step
instead I'm just going to dump a massive
pile of markup that's way too much for
you to read but you're just gonna have
to trust me that there's nothing
actually difficult about it all it does
is it iterates over the itineraries and
for each one it displays loads of
bootstrapped related elements that's
going to displace to flight the airport
codes we're using this other component
to display the flight segments and then
we're displaying the airline name and
the price and things like that so
assuming all that works correctly then
back in the browser when I add stuff to
my shortlist we're now going to get
these attractive looking cards popping
up that show us the stuff that's been
added to the shortlist there okay so
that is an example of how we can add a
new feature to our application and how
we can tie it into the existing
structure of state management that's in
that okay that's good but hey let's do
something a little bit more interesting
still let's build an even more advanced
component now I keep claiming to you
that components are very flexible and
can do lots of things but so far I've
all I've shown you is that you can use
one component inside another and you can
pass parameters into them what are the
cool things can we do with components
let's see well to give it to invent a
reason for why we should do this let's
think a little bit about the user
experience of this website right now
excuse me there's one or two UX problems
there's probably loads of problems
really but one assume that I want to
focus on right now is what happens when
I click this search button repeatedly
now as you know it's going to return
different random dates or each time and
it takes about half a second to return
every time and the reason for that is
because I just put in a hard code at
half second delay but of course in the
real world that things do take a nonzero
amount of time so the user probably will
have to wait for some amount of time for
their search results to come back but
we're not displaying any kind of
indication that we're loading and
waiting so the user has no idea that
we've really even acknowledged their
click on the button also while they are
waiting for the new state to arrive the
old results below and now stale and
obsolete and useless but we're still
presenting them as if they're up today
so that's really strange and misleading
that you can click on the button and it
shows your old results and you don't
even know that they're not the new ones
so to solve these UX problems
want to do a different thing when you
click on the search button
I want to gray out all the stuff in the
UI below it so that you can see that
it's old data you don't need it anymore
and we're loading something in the
background ok but since I'm a programmer
I don't just want to implement grey and
Gao in a sort of one-off way I want to
invent a general framework for graying
out anything anytime anywhere on no
notice I can just grow your stuff out
anytime I like with a general system ok
and I'm gonna do that using a blazer
component that can gray stuff out how
could a component do that let's see I'm
gonna add a new item and I'm gonna call
this one gray out zone and I know that
text is too small to read anyway here's
our gray out zone and I want the gray
zone to be able to toggle whether or not
stuff is currently grayed out so I want
it to have this boolean parameter called
is grayed out that can get passed in
from outside and then as for what markup
that should render is going to be like
this now if you know CSS this will
probably seem quite straightforward to
you and if you don't it might be that
you don't really get what I'm doing but
don't worry about it it's not hugely
interesting it's just some fairly basic
CSS stuff so what I'm doing here I'm
saying that we've got a CSS class of
gray out but only if that boolean flag
is true and when that flag is true we're
going to have this element here called
cover or with this with a style named
cover and I've set up the CSS already so
that the cover element completely fills
up the boundaries of its parent using
absolute positioning and it displays a
sort of translucent gray box so it
covers things over and prevents you from
interacting with the stuff that's behind
it and it's only going to be there if
this gray out class is enabled so
whatever goes here is the thing that's
going to get grayed out which is good so
I can put my UI in there but remember I
want a completely general system for
graying out anything
so what UI is going to go in there well
I don't know I just need some sort of
placeholder to represent the idea of an
arbitrary piece
user interface and that's a feature that
we have that's quite convenient so I can
take another parameter of type render
fragment and a render fragment
represents an arbitrary piece of user
interface that can be rendered and you
can choose wherever you want to render
it so I've got some child content and I
want to render that child content right
there so it's the child content that's
going to be grayed out and now I've done
that I can go back to my main and I can
use my gray out zone so what do I want
to grow out I want to grow out the
search results so I'm going to wrap a
gray out zone around the search results
like that okay and then I want to pass
this boolean flag is grayed out there
and I'm going to say that this thing is
grayed out if and only if we've
currently got a search in progress okay
let's see if it works shall we back in
the browser going to reload and now when
I click on the search bar and you'll see
that that bit of the UI below gets
nicely grayed out while ever we've got a
search in progress and we can of course
reuse our gray out zone wherever we want
to do the same trick elsewhere so that's
another cool thing that we can do with
components okay let's move on to our
fourth thing that we can do in Blazer
applications and that is JavaScript
Interop okay so I'm sure that you can
probably anticipate scenarios where you
would need to call into JavaScript code
from your.net for example you might want
to call browser api's browsers have got
lots of api's that let your applications
do all kinds of things from very simple
things like just focusing an element to
things like switching into full screen
merge or even using the payment requests
API to ask your user to give them some
to give you some money and you might
want to use any of those api's or you
might want to integrate with third-party
JavaScript libraries so that is a thing
that we want to let you do so what's the
scenario for JavaScript Interop in
flight finder well let's imagine that I
am a very price-sensitive user and I
want to get the cheapest flight I can
and since I know that this is just
random data I'm just going to keep
clicking the search button over and over
again until I eventually find a really
good deal okay so I've got a very cheap
deal here one hundred and sixty seven
dollars for this fly I'm really pleased
with myself finding that so I'm gonna
add that into my short list brilliant
super happy about that but then since
I'm a user and users are generally just
Matt and they do crazy things for no
reason at all for for no reason that
anyone can think of I'm now going to
reload the page okay and when I reload
the page what's going to happen to my
short list well it's gonna get lost oh
no I'm a very sad user now so clearly
what we want to do is it have some way
of preserving the short list across page
loads and most of the web developers in
the audience will probably think that's
going to be easy if we can use
JavaScript then we can just store stuff
in local storage and it's just going to
be there and it'll be nice and
persistent and you're right and that's
exactly what we're going to do so we
want to use JavaScript Interop to source
um store some stuff in browser local
storage but do you know what's even
easier than using javascript interrupts
api's it's not using JavaScript Interop
here guys
it's just letting someone else do that
work for you that's a general tip for
life by the way I would strongly
recommend always just let other people
do stuff for you and that's a thing that
we're going to be able to do right now
so I want to add local storage
capabilities to my application but I
want someone else to do that for me so
I'm going to go and have a look at what
NuGet packages exist new Gary's dotnet
package management system if you didn't
know and I can go in there I can see
what packages exist well let's have a
look I happen to know that there's this
thing that I found earlier called cloud
crate asp net core blazer browser
storage super name i imagine some kind
of PR agency came up with that really
cool and he adds blazer local and
sessions storage support alright and
it's made by this wonderful person
called florian door and off and that is
going to give us just the functionality
that we want so the point I'm making
with all this is although you can do
JavaScript interrupts directly yourself
and I'm going to show you that in like
five minutes
we also want to make sure that you don't
always have to it should be possible to
pull in packages where other people have
figured out the details for you and
there just give you some nice dotnet
api's to work with and that's what I'm
gonna do now
so I've read the docs for this package
already and I know that the way to use
it is to register local storage as a
service in my dependency injection
system so in Blaser the dependency
injection system is configured here in
programmed RCS and so for example this
is where I'm telling you the apps there
is one of the singletons that can get
injected into any of my components and I
can add other stuff here as well so now
I've got that package installed I'm
gonna say services dot add storage
alright and I need a namespace import
for that and that's gonna make local and
session storage available as a DI
service so I could now use that in any
of my components or in my state
container and I want to use it in the
state container so I'm going to change
the constructor parameters for app state
I'm going to say I want to get an
instance of local storage bank being
passed in here and I'll call that local
storage instance ok and then I need to
store that in a field on my class here
so I can use it and I'll make a private
read-only local storage call that local
storage and I'm going to set the value
of that to be whatever gets passed in to
the constructor all right so now I've
got my local storage I can use that
where do I want to use that well I want
to use it here inside might add to
shortlist I'm going to say whenever you
add stuff to a short list I want to save
the updated version of it so I'm going
to say local storage dot set item and
then it wants me to give a key so let's
call it I don't know a short list that
would make sense and then what do we
want to store in there
well we store everything that's in this
short list right now ok let's see if
this works then shall we
I'm gonna go back into my browser now
and I want to show you firstly what
happens when I try to evaluate what's in
local storage already and the answer is
nothing
I've got nothing in local storage yet
but when I click on one of the
add buttons now to add something to
shortlist and we evaluate it again
you'll see we've now got all this stuff
in there we've got all this JSON
serialize representation of the data
that I've just added okay so it's
working
we're interoperating with local storage
so does that mean we're done
if I hit reload right now is my $549
flight still going to be there let's
find out the answer is no why is it not
there that's because although we've
implemented some logic for saving
something in local storage we've not
implemented any logic for loading it
back it's not very difficult though
we'll do that as follows we will say ok
local storage please have a look is
there anything that's stored under this
key of short list if there is
deserialize it's going to be an array of
itineraries and then if you've got that
we're going to add it into the new short
list array that's in the new instance of
the application ok so now if I hit
reload one more time instead of starting
off empty you'll see it starts off with
the stuff that's been loaded back from
local storage so that does work and well
done cloud create people for making that
lovely thing for us that's all very good
but I know you're thinking oh that's
very nice but that's cheating because
you're just using a package that our
execs already exists what if I have to
write the JavaScript Interop stuff
myself what if I want to do something
that there is no package for or I just
need to do some other custom thing so I
will show you but I'm going to show you
in the context of another hopefully
interesting scenario and that is library
projects so you're familiar with the
idea of normal class library projects
that allow you to reuse chunks of
c-sharp in other projects well there's a
blazer equivalent to that it's called a
blazer library project and it lets you
include not only just regular dotnet
code but also you can include blazer UI
components in there as well and reuse
them and share them and also you can
include static content such as CSS or
images or JavaScript whatever you want
and you can bundle all that stuff into a
project that you reuse and if you're
feeling particularly generous you can
even publish it to NuGet so that other
people can use it as well and that is
how the class
a package was created so let me give you
an example of doing that now you
probably would think that the way to
create a blazer library project if you
know a visual studio would be to go add
new project and go through there well
that is the way it should work but we
haven't yet implemented AVS template for
it we really ought to get on with doing
that but we just haven't done yeah so
for now the only way to create a blazing
a library project is on the command line
in fact you can create any blazer
project on the command line once you've
installed the blazer packages when you
go net new you'll see that alongside all
the other things you can create we can
create some blazer stuff so we can
create a blazer hostert projects we can
create a blazer standalone project and
most relevant for us right now we can
create a blazer library or blazer live
for short so I want to do that right now
Frank let me zoom back in so you can see
what I'm typing and when I say a.net new
blazer lib and we specify where we want
that to go and I want it to be called my
blazer library okay so we'll create that
and that will put all the files on disk
and then we will need to go into vs and
add that to our solution so I'm going to
go add existing project and then I'll
quickly skip through all these menus to
find the one I want which is this one
and then that is now added as a fourth
project now a solution and obviously
that would be all automated when we've
got a vs template okay now I want to add
a reference from my client library to my
new blazer library so that I can start
to use it so I'm going to go add
reference and then I'll choose my blazer
library up there ok very good okay so
we've got a reference and there's one
other thing that you need to do right
now if you want to consume a blazer
library project and it's pretty weird
and it's not very nice and we need to
fix this and make it so you don't have
to do it but I'm afraid right now when
you add a new blazer library project you
have to go to your view imports file and
manually add this weird thing outside
helper everything from my blazer library
okay so I appreciate that strange and
we'll come up with some solution that
means you don't have to do that but for
now you do alright so now I've added a
reference
to this my Blaser library and since I've
done that I can consume whatever's in
there let's see what is in there shall
we so what we've got inside that is
we've got a blazer component component
one or CS HTML and what's that well it
just displays some static HTML but it's
a normal blazer component and it can do
anything that blazer components can do
also we've got some static content we've
got some CSS we've got a background PNG
image and we've got some stuff for Jace
interrupts I'll show you in a minute
okay so let's have a go at using
component 1 inside our flight finder
client let's say that for whatever
reason I want to put component 1 at the
top of my search resource so I'm going
to go in here and I'm going to say
please give me a component 1 right there
if you don't mind now I've done that if
I come back and reload then we should
see here we go here's our component 1
this plays a component is defined in the
my Blaser library package and that shows
you that you can put whatever stuff you
want in there including static content
because you can see the red dotted
outline there that's defined in the CSS
file and you can see the stripey
background that's defined as a PNG a PNG
image inside the package as well so you
can bundle everything that you need for
your components into libraries and then
you can reuse them across projects if
you want to and you can publish them to
new gap if you want to okay so that's
using components but let's get back to
the JavaScript Interop ok how does that
really work so here's an example of
doing it manually so I've got here this
static c-sharp method called prompt and
it's going to take a message as yeah
message which is a type string and it's
going to return a string and what it
actually does is it's going to invoke
some JavaScript and the syntax for
invoking JavaScript is like this
registered function dot invoke and then
you can pass some stuff into it and you
can get some stuff back out and you have
to give the identify over a thing that's
being registered and then to actually
render it register it you write some
JavaScript or type script or
CoffeeScript or every other thing you
like so here I've got a JavaScript file
and it registers this function with that
identifier and it's a normal JavaScript
function which takes
message parameter and the implementation
is very simple it's simply going to
display a prompt using the browsers
native prompt feature so it calls prompt
passes the message and it's going to
return whatever value gets returned so
that's how you can do JavaScript and
drop and you don't have to do it in
library packages if you don't want you
can put these files in your main project
but I just wanted to show you the
library packages as well so let's try
and use it shall we
I'm going to try and use this inside my
state container I'll say that when
you've done a search and whenever we've
got some results come back I want to say
example J's Interop I want to call
prompt and I'll pass my message okay so
if that works then when I'm back in the
browser now and I click on search and we
get some results you'll see it's worked
it's called into the JavaScript it's
passed through my message from the
dotnet code and whatever the user types
whatever the user types in here will get
passed back into the dotnet code so
that's a very simple example but
hopefully you can see that you can put
completely arbitrary JavaScript logic in
there to interact with third-party
libraries or to call any browser API
that you want to and then you can if you
want to put it in a library package
reuse it publish it to new gap if you
feel like all right so we are basically
out of time now so I've shown you a
whole bunch of things that you can do
with a slightly more advanced project
that hopefully gives you a sense of what
it's like to build this sort of thing
now I need to remind you one further
time that this is not a shipping product
this is an experimental idea and it's my
hope at least and the hope of many of us
that this will become a shipping product
but that's not decided yet we honestly
don't know and whether or not that
happens is largely going to depend and
what feedback we get from potential
customers potential users of this
product so I really would like you as
much as possible to give us feedback
through any channels that you can about
whether you think this is useful to you
whether you would use it what you don't
like about it maybe just give us some
ideas what you think about this thing to
give you a slightly broader picture of
all the functionality we would have in
mind for a sort of version one of
if it was to become a thing well
obviously I've been showing you this
component model in some detail but
there's other more basic features as
well like layout some routing they'd be
familiar to most web developers they're
already implemented I didn't bother
showing nukes it's just not very
interesting what else is there well
obviously there needs to be very
first-class tooling support we haven't
got everything in there yet so we
haven't got all the project templates
right there's still one or two quirks in
the intellisense but you know we've got
a lot of the basics in there already
we've got dependency injection which
I've shown you using we have not yet got
but obviously we would need for typical
business applications a comprehensive
system of working with entering data so
all your usual forms and validation
stuff needs to be very slick and nice to
work with obviously you would have to
have debugging support now at the moment
we don't have support for debugging
the.net that's running in your browser
we do have a proof-of-concept of it
actually so you know when you open your
browser dev tools and you can see your
JavaScript you can set breakpoints on it
and step through it and so on
we've got a prototype already of making
it so that you see your c-sharp source
code inside the dev tools and you can
set breakpoints on it there and step
through it and that's really lovely so
hopefully we will do something like that
but there's quite a lot of work involved
in making that really robust stone to
end so that's another thing that's in
progress auto rebuild means whenever you
change your sources it just
automatically builds and updates in the
browser JavaScript Interop I showed you
some of that
server-side rendering I didn't show you
it's not implemented yet but it would
very very simple for us to implement
because Blaser components can run on the
server just as well as they can run on
the client salt now after all if you've
got that done out on the server so we
can easily render the initial
application UI on the server so the user
can see that without even having to
download any of the JavaScript and web
assembly component packages I showed you
that publishing just works when you
publish it gets all the right files in
the right place whether you're deploying
to Azure or your own servers or anything
else assembly trimming that means that
every time you build we figure out which
parts of the assemblies you're not using
and we strip them out because it's very
important that the resulting application
is as small as it needs to be when it
runs in the browser so we've already
implemented some of that but we have got
plans to take that even further and then
finally what
browsers that don't even support
webassembly you probably would think
that there's no way they're going to run
these applications but the cool thing is
they will they will run it and that's
because webassembly is designed to fall
back on an older standard called Assam
jeaious and we've got that already so
when the application is started up it
detects whether the browser supports
webassembly
and if it doesn't it loads a different
version of the mono runtime which is
compiled to Assam je s so even on older
browsers like I 11 are probably older
the applications will work as well so
that is all we have time for I hope that
is of some interest to you and I hope
you'll try it out and give us some
feedback if you go to this website laser
dot now you'll get all the instructions
for downloading it and there's a lot of
documentation about how to use it so um
so yeah that's it we're out of time
I hope that's been fun and I hope you
enjoy the rest of the conference
please remember to evaluate the session
on the way out to determine what the
agenda is going to be next year and have
a really good rest of your time here
[Applause]
[Music]